My sodium levels, I'm talking about blood sodium levels, have been low in the past few
blood tests that I've had done. What causes low sodium in what is the best way to
get it back up again? Well sodium ranges typically from normal lab tests range.
However there's a difference between lab range and functional range or what's called optimal
range. So lab range is typically wider than a functional range is typically tighter. So I think
the lab range for sodium is like 135 to 145 or 146. The functional range is a little bit tighter,
137 to 142 or 143. If they're low, what causes low sodium? Well first of all sodium
isn't one of your electrolytes. So it maintains the osmotic pressure in your blood.
It helps maintain an acid base balance. Sodium functions in cells, in muscle contraction. It
functions in your nerves, in the impulse transmission. If your sodium is too low, it can affect your heart.
And the question is what causes low sodium? So common cause of low sodium with the
adrenal fatigue. That's a very common cause of low sodium. I wouldn't say it's the most common.
Probably the most common is taking diuretics. So I don't remember who asked this question,
but the question we get asked is, are you taking diuretics? So if you're taking diuretics
to get water off your body, then that can decrease your sodium levels. If you're not taking
diuretics and you have adema, so if you have a lot of swelling in your legs, that can cause low
sodium levels in your blood. So probably the most common is taking diuretics.
More serious issues with low sodium would be what's called anisins disease. Adisins disease is a
disease of the adrenal glands where it impairs your resorption of sodium. Sodium is supposed to be
resorbed from a hormone that's released by the adrenal glands. It's then resorbed in the kidneys
and retained. And you'll get excess spillage of sodium into your urine with adisins disease.
But common would be taking diuretics. Another common would be adema. And then another common would be
adrenal fatigue. So if persons that are a lot of stress, they have adrenal fatigue. Well, how else would
you measure if it's adrenal fatigue? Then doing a Dutch test, or if you don't want to spend the
money in a Dutch test for maybe $150 you can do in adrenal cortisol test, where you do a sample,
a saliva sample, four times in a day. I think it's right before bed, right when you wake up in the
morning at noon and then in the afternoon. And then you measure your cortisol curve. That's also done
in the Dutch test as well. But that could give you that will tell you really the how your aderitals
are doing. The reason I like the Dutch test is also tested for DHEA, which is also a hormone that's
released by the aderitals. So if a person has adrenal fatigue, they're going to have a flattened
other cortisol curve. They'll have low DHEA. And then that will relate to the low sodium levels.
Now, of course, if you're on diuretics, you'd have to go I look at drug interaction first.
That'd be the most common. If you're not on diuretics and you don't have adema, then it's most likely
adrenal fatigue. So if you don't, if whoever asks this question, is that, well, I'm not on diuretics.
I don't have adema. Then I would support this. Then you don't want to do a test for your aderitals.
You could support your aderials by taking adaptogens and taking some electrolytes. So how would you
treat it? So always you treat something by fixing the cause first. So if I have low sodium levels,
you don't just jump right in and go, okay, I'm just going to take more electrolytes and I'm going
to eat more salt because it could be because you're excreting this not because you don't have enough
sodium. So you want to find that cause. But if you said, no, I'm not on any diuretics. No, I don't have
adema. Then it's most likely adrenal insufficiency and then you'd support that by taking adaptogens or
so adrenal tissue to help support your aderials and then to take electrolytes. You could take an
electrolyte powder. An electrolyte powder is going to be sodium chloride and some other minerals in it.
Most mineral supplements aren't going to have a lot of sodium. I've had people with low sodium
when they get to this is just that they're that they're that they start taking just putting salty
their food a little bit more. Now you got to be careful of that because sodium chloride just adding
salt to your food. Maybe a person has low sodium because they have adrenal fatigue and like you
made a comment here, maybe because you're doing solos every day. Then and most likely adrenal fatigue.
And then you say, well, I'm just going to add salt to my diet. You have to be careful because
if you've gone through the autoimmune course at all, in the last part of the autoimmune course,
I think it's the last module is a course on Hashimoto's. People with Hashimoto's can have a salt
sensitivity and that can flare their autoimmune disease. It's not super common but it it's not
that uncommon either. So you do have to be aware of that with using just sodium chloride. If you have
to increase your sodium by adding more sodium chloride, then you do have to take more potassium.
And I do have a whole I think I have a whole video on that in the autoimmune course.
So also look at that. Also, you got to look at some people are sensitive and that sodium
causes blood pressure changes. So only a percentage of people that that happens to
but just be aware of that. If you do have a blood pressure cuff at home, make sure you monitor that.
So if you're going to take an electrolyte with sodium or you're just going to
increase salt consumption, I would suggest that you do check your blood pressure
unless the person's 20 years old and that's all worried about that. But if you're over 50,
you should probably be checking your blood pressure with that as well.
Yeah. And I don't know if I went over any blood whoever asked this question. I don't remember
who I guess it was you, Bobby, because you're the one making these comments on the chat or Debi making
these comments on the chat that I don't remember if I went over your blood work with you because
whenever you look at your blood work, you don't look at numbers solely individually. You look at
how they relate to other things and there's different patterns that flow. Now sodium is one of
those. That's easy to answer the question because it isn't as quite related to other markers in
your CBC or complete metabolic panel. So the answers that I gave you are pretty straightforward.
So if you're not on any drug diuretics, you're not on you don't have any signs of adema
adema that you've got to think of adrenal insubitancy as the cause. Could you lose a lot of
electrolytes doing the sauna? Depends on how much a person sweats. Depends on how long you're doing
the sauna. Yes, you can you will lose electrolytes sweating, but still you should have a balance of that.
But also, of course, it's on a very low sodium diet for other reasons or they just don't like salt
or they don't drink a lot of salt. Typically, one of that's one of the signs of adrenal insubitancy
that is that they crave salt. So you know, it's one of the telltale signs that it's such
crave salty food, you know, that you're going to think of it should at least be a red flag for
as a practitioner to go what if this person has adrenal insubitancy and doing a cortisol
test, an adrenal stress test it's called is something that should be discussed at least.